we have a lot to get to this morning
john but first we want to get over to
nate tannenbaum who's at home
with some news on the traffic front hi
nate
good morning alex good morning john and
thank you for getting your day started
with us on a good day las vegas from the
bowtie nate home studio the freeways are
in pretty good shape right now but we're
taking it down to the las vegas strip
which is closed right now between elvis
presley boulevard and spring mountain
anyone who drives there knows a couple
of things first of all there's just not
a whole lot of traffic there during the
overnight hours
but the bottom line there's also
construction there there's also now
police activity we have a live camera
taking a look there
there were a couple of police cars there
just moments ago it looks like we've got
the construction cones there but you see
no cars
once again las vegas boulevard is closed
between elvis presley boulevard and
spring mountain will continue to keep
you posted throughout the show